all right hi how's that hello everyone
my name is Simon Remley and this is my
colleague Deena Patel we're from the New
York City mayor's office of data
analytics and we're just gonna walk
through one of the projects we recently
did where we relied a lot on Python
around providing free school lunches to
to every student in New York City Public
Schools I'm just gonna do a quick intro
for anyone
show of hands has anyone heard of us
before oh there you go Wow okay I'm
flattered yeah so we are a very small
team of currently are we six yeah we're
six right now inside the mayor's office
and we act as even though I hate to use
the term a we're sort of like an
internal data consulting function for
the city in that we are available for
free to any city agency that has a
problem or perhaps issues with using
data or wants to use data more
effectively and that can span a you know
a wide range of different sort of
applications which is why we have this
sort of rudimentary pyramid here about
the way we think about data analytics
meaning we'd all like to spend our days
fitting really cool models and doing
some neural nets and whatever but that's
really the tip of the pyramid and to get
a city agency or team to the point where
they're able to use those kind of things
effectively we have to start by managing
their data and making sure that it's
intelligible to to human brains to begin
with and and that really is the bulk of
our work so you know the reason we have
this pyramid is because it's wider at
the base we do more work at the base and
we try to get to the top so you know
that that's maybe the frame of reference
we try to use for analytics and I guess
to segue into what we're actually gonna
be talking about oftentimes we get work
from the strangest places the the
project Dena is going to talk about
today came completely out of the blue
when
met with the Department of Education bus
routing team they were interested in in
routing buses more effectively which is
frankly a problem that I don't think the
six of us are fully capable of handling
right now but there was someone else in
the room who was in charge of the do
ease meal provision so the the way the
Department provides school lunches to to
every student in the city and they had a
very curious problem for that they
shared with us and that's how this all
got started I'm gonna turn it over to
Dina now because she is the expert on on
the thing itself
thank you everyone wow this is a full
room this is exciting to have you all
here so we of course we all know that
there is actually no such thing as a
free lunch so who actually pays we have
the New York City Department of
Education or your any local school
district right they're the ones who
actually administer the program and
they're the ones who will actually apply
to the federal government to get
reimbursements so this is what was
brought to us they said look there's
this program out there and it's a little
bit different from the traditional way
that we have been receiving lunch
reimbursements can you help us with it
so traditionally lunch reimbursements
actually fall under the US Department of
Agriculture not the Education Department
so it's interesting right there you see
that this was actually a program meant
to pay farmers for food and as a
secondary effect you would feed kids so
it's just interesting to have that kind
of background and then the of course the
school kids themselves are the ones who
also pay into the program and they would
traditionally pay at different levels so
depending on their family's income so
you would say oh this the student their
family makes very little money they
have to pay anything but we're gonna get
back most of that money from the USDA
but here's another kid whose family
makes a little bit more and so they'll
have to pay a little bit more into the
program but and we're gonna get a little
more from a little bit less from the
USDA for that kid and then there'll be
the kids who make just too much money
and they have to pay all of it
themselves so it's still not a it's
still like maybe three dollars a lunch
so not a huge amount but for those kids
we only get a few cents back from the
USDA so already you're setting up this
tiered systems where certain kids would
would get stigmatized and because of
this advocates pushed for universal free
lunches for for all all students and as
part of this all students would have to
receive the meals at no cost all meals
would be reimbursed by the federal
government in the same way within a
school so one of these such programs
that they came up with is called CEP and
there are multiple ones I'm not an
expert on these different programs this
is one that New York City is using
currently and this is a program that was
started maybe a handful of years ago and
has been in kind of a pilot phase and so
I think the last few years in New York
City was using this on their on their
middle school so not all the schools
with just the middle school this year
they were saying oh we want to expand it
to all of the schools which is why they
actually wanted our help with it so it's
actually this program is based on the
percentage of what they call identified
students in a school and these
identified students are ones whose
families may be receiving food stamps or
part of some other federal program that
the basically the Department of
Education can match them back to one of
these other programs
and so and there for some reason they
call them identified students so
whatever the percentage is in that
school that's gonna determine what kind
of reimbursements they get the the trick
to it though is it's not just the school
itself but schools can be grouped
together and so and what we'll walk
through that a little bit but
essentially there's really no constraint
on how to group schools and so I you
know there's a lot of great kind of
titles for this project and you know one
of them is like free lunch for all but
another one is how we basically Gerry
mater gerrymandered the school systems
of New York City to get more federal
reimbursements so and and actually what
we've come up with can be used for any
local school district it doesn't have to
be you know I'm sure New York City is
probably the biggest school district in
the in the US with over a million
students in over 1,500 schools so this
is already a huge problem or just a you
know quantitatively a big problem and so
but the analytics question here is
what's the best way to group schools to
maximize reimbursements in order to take
full advantage of this of this federal
program the kind of spoiler here is that
New York City actually didn't they came
to us this past summer to do this and
they said oh we're gonna expand it all
the schools are going to be involved how
do we do this
in the end there was some administrative
change and it turns out they were
already at the maximum reimbursement
that they could get and they ended up
not really needing our our algorithm so
we put all this work into it and they're
like oh just kidding we don't need it
but it's still it's it was still an
interesting project and it's still
something that I think other school
districts could use because it is a
federal program
so I'm just going to walk through now
the the the reimbursement rules the
rules that we had to follow on this
program so also all lunches are going to
be reimbursed that either with free rate
or the paid rate so imagine this is this
is and this threshold is where
everything below the threshold you're
going to be reimbursed at the higher
rate and everything after at the lower
rate and that particular the threshold
is actually depends on that percentage
of identified students and it's
multiplied by this multiplier of 1.6
which is just a multiplier they put in
there and the threshold has to be less
than hundred percent so you can imagine
the threshold could go over a hundred
percent because you have this one point
six multiplier but it's capped at a
hundred and there's actually also a
minimum value so you can't be part of
this program unless you meet the minimum
so this slide has a lot of equations on
it so just bear with me and actually I
will also say that all of this stuff is
on our github account so and it's
actually pretty well documented we have
a an eye Python notebook that walks
through all of this stuff so if you
don't get it here don't worry this is
just to give you like an overview if
you're interested more please go and
look at our github so the goal is just
to maximize the reimbursements which are
basically the number of lunches times
the the price of the lunch multiplied by
the threshold and the same thing for the
number of breakfasts because this
includes breakfasts and lunches for the
kids and the way I've kind of written
out this equation I've just put the
everyone is is reimbursed at the base
rate no matter what so I kind of just
put that off to the side that's just to
make the optimization a little bit
easier to look at but that part doesn't
depend on the groupings so one thing you
can do is you can think about okay how
do we actually group schools and what's
going to be the difference if we group
them versus not group them so that's a
Delta r1 - the difference between having
them grouped so that's going to tell us
if we have two schools whether or not we
should group them or not well it turns
out that you know if you do a little bit
of algebra you can come up with which is
which is interesting because it's what's
important there is a difference in the
threshold so threshold - - threshold one
that that's an important part of it and
then the other important part is m1
minus m2 and I kind of call these M's
they're basically like the meal per
student and this is this is essentially
the number of meals per student at that
school and ends are the number of
students so that final bit of it is
actually the thing is like the harmonic
mean of of the number of students in the
in the two schools just kind of less
important but so the interesting thing
is that if the two thresholds are the
same it doesn't matter how you group
them you get you get you zero to zero it
out so yeah so you see the one where the
thresholds are the same are one two zero
same thing if m1 and m2 are the same you
basically you have this symmetry so
again it doesn't matter you can group
them or you cannot group them what this
matter is when you have them off on a
diagonal like this now it makes a
more sense to group them you're going to
get a higher reimbursement from goop
grouping them versus not so that just
gives you some kind of feeling into how
we this is how we kind of first started
looking at this problem is try to take
it simple steps first and break it down
and see okay can we do anything
analytical with it okay
sisters are my first idea when I got
this problem like oh yeah we can do this
we'll just do all the combinations of
course anyone who's done anything with
things like the Traveling Salesman
problem or problems like that you know
that that's that's not going to work so
and luckily you know and I was always
researching this I saw oh there's this
thing called a stirling partition number
and this is the number of number of ways
of grouping a set of objects so the
number of ways of grouping three objects
into two groups is illustrated up here
we can count these on our fingers it's
three great as soon as we get to 30 the
number of ways of grouping 30 things
into ten groups now we're at you know 10
to the 23 like there's even even with
just 30 schools this this method is
gonna fail and of course 100 you know
doesn't work but in New York City is
over 1500 schools there's no way we're
going to get anywhere close to this by
doing it this way so we actually tried a
number of different approaches and but
the one that we found to be kind of the
most elegant was was Monte Carlo and so
this is based on the metropolis Hastings
money color method which maybe some of
you are familiar with and so it's really
just five simple steps that you were
feed over and over the first step is you
you randomly group group the schools
into different groups and you could do
that or you could just I think what we
ended up doing is putting everyone into
one group to start with so you could
just initial
your problem somehow and then you take a
step so in our case a step was changing
one school in a group and putting it
into another group so after that then
you compare the difference in
reimbursements if it was good if it was
you know if it was good if it was better
than what you had before you keep it if
it wasn't then you reject it and you
start over so you'll notice that this
except to reject that number four step
so in like metropolis Hastings this is a
really important step because it lets
you figure out you like your probability
distributions right if you get the right
detailed balance and all this is a good
way of simulating very complicated
distributions in our case we didn't care
about that we're just trying to figure
out what's the optimal reimbursement so
this method is also called stochastic
hill climbing which i think is such a
great name for it because it's exactly
what it is you keep you know you walk in
a random direction if you get higher on
the mountain you you you plant your foot
there if you don't then you go back to
your initial step so I can't take credit
for this picture I actually stole it off
the someone else's talk but I love it
because you know what do we do about
local maxima right so maybe we can't
take any more steps maybe we started out
we're just gonna be stuck there what do
we do about that so we we tried another
method called simulated annealing which
actually lets you take some backward
steps like okay it kind of relaxes that
if your step is bad it kind of still
lets you take it some of the time so the
idea there is that maybe you'll you'll
hit a local global Maxima so it's a very
similar it's a very similar algorithm
the only difference is in your accept
and reject
if it's if delta r is greater than zero
you still always accept but if it's less
than zero then you only accept with a
probability of e raised to Delta R over
T so T is like this made-up parameter
and it's it's essentially you know it's
modeled off physical systems where it be
temperature in this case it doesn't
really mean anything except that we want
to keep doing this and at the same time
we let T go to zero so this is is
essentially what the function looks like
at different values of T so you can see
as you let T go to zero you're again
approximating that step function that
that you know was in in the previous
case right so essentially as as this
goes to zero we're getting back this to
Castaic hill climbing okay so I think
I'm going to hand it over to Simon to
tell us a little bit about how we kind
of implemented this and made it run
faster because we're doing a whole bunch
of these at once I am gonna pull up the
actual code for this part yeah we did
write code just just so everyone knows I
think what's worth pointing out here is
that when we did this originally we just
wrote code off the top of our heads and
we didn't really pay attention to
efficiency and it took a long time on
the order of 11 minutes to do this for I
think a hundred iterations so then you
want to do it over and over and over
again to make sure that you're actually
getting a good stable solution and it's
not like we were writing you know
incredibly stupid like three times
nested for loops or anything it just
took a long time without using the
pandas group by operator which I think
I've been using pandas for I know three
or four years at this point and it
really took me a long time to figure out
how to use it well so I'm guessing
everyone in the room is already totally
comfortable with it but I just want to
like for I'd like to make a poll
of showing how it really helped save the
day in terms of not having to run this
thing overnight or on the weekend and
everything Dina's described so far you
know this this reimbursement calculation
is all right there it's just one group
buy and if you're if you're new to
pandas I guess or maybe you're coming
from the world of sequel or something
you're used to a group by being an
operation like you do a query you get it
back grouped and and and you're
comfortable with that but what's really
nifty about it in pandas and you
probably already know this but for the
sake of completeness it's also an object
so here in this function we just group
we're grouping by these arbitrary
gerrymandered school groupings that we
discussed and you do it once you can see
it in the top line there and from there
you can do whatever operations you want
however many times you want in this case
we're just summing you know we're doing
different sums but you can do whatever
and it is way faster to carry that thing
around with you group it once and then
do what you want however many times
before you group again and to go back to
the presentation this is the difference
it makes so we go from eleven and a half
minutes for a hundred iterations to
about a minute and I know that won't
impress any like high-frequency trading
people put it made a big difference for
us and if you know in the interest of
time it's all up on the github will
share the link and if you have any
questions about about that I'm happy to
talk afterwards now for the fun part
we're gonna show a video this is like
the fun horse race video of it actually
happening and you can see how
unfortunately we're not showing how
schools like move back and forth between
groups but you can see the optimal group
slowly forming over time and you can see
we seeded it with ten groups just
randomly every school got placed in one
of ten groups and running it over the
course of
how many was this yeah but you can see
um you get and this happens in almost
every every time you run this is you end
up with what is one group of with a
hundred percent threshold so where
everyone is reimbursed 100 percent of
the time and you end up with a middle
group in the eighty-five percent range
and then a lot of schools end up
interestingly but you know makes sense
considering the math they end up right
above the 64 percent threshold so
they're like they just squeak into the
program by a hair and you can kind of
see that with the the decimals like some
of those are it's point 6 4 to the 5th
decimal and in order to counter for that
the ones we actually submitted you know
they had a little bit of padding built
in so that if like one kid leaves this
does no fall apart this is another way
of looking at the same thing sort of the
different groups this time in a scatter
plot you know with the two relevant
variables the meals per student on the
y-axis and this this reimbursement
threshold on the x-axis and sort of I
guess in the vein of of doctor Gilman's
talked earlier about showing workflow on
methods this is a comparison of the
different things we tried the the most
basic obvious one is to make each school
in its own group which reimbursed about
180 ish million dollars looks like
putting all the schools in one group
isn't that bad you get like two yeah
and then these these other methods we're
not going to go into them but they were
like deterministic greedy algorithms
that we just we did the same thing but
deterministically and they would
inevitably get stuck or have have
strange results that didn't lead to a
good place but the the stochastic
methods at on the top performed better
what you can't see here is because of
the scale it's a little hard to tell how
much difference it makes but it makes
about
eleven million dollars of difference in
the total budget which is like on the
order of seven eight percent of the
total school budget that you can just
conjure out of thin air by by doing this
gerrymandering and just sort of put a
bow around it there is what happened
this school year was from the
perspective of every kid in the school
system really great which is that it
just so happened that by a hair there
were enough eligible children registered
in New York that this doesn't matter
that you can just put them all in one
group and get full reimbursement but it
literally was by I think three decimal
places like the threshold is sixty-four
percent and I think New York City has a
whole this year had like point six four
zero zero zero eight so next year that
might not be the case in which case we
can do this again and then we can get
close to the same amount of money and if
you're a another reasonably large school
district that has you know ten or more
schools you can do this too and it's all
based on this USDA sort of regulatory
arbitrage that we're doing I'm not sure
whether we should tell them to be honest
but yeah that's kind of the long short
of it if you have any questions of one
thing I should mention is we just
recently published online on our github
github pages this along with several
other products we've done so here's free
lunch there's also one we did on
Legionnaires disease back in 2015 and
another first source of income
discrimination each of them has a
write-up you know a bridge version of
what we talked about here and each of
them has a github with some notebooks or
other you know code in it so feel free
to peruse at your leisure and that's
that's it for us right any questions
[Applause]
sure so the question was what was the
penalty to using more groupings so why
did we end up using this arbitrary ten
yeah yeah and correct me if I'm wrong
but III think we were more or less told
by the administrators of the program
that we should aim for ten or fewer
because more would be both a gigantic
administrative hurdle and might raise
weird eyebrows if we all of a sudden
have like thirty seven groups that that
appear out of nowhere so it was more or
less just one of implementation ten and
they had ten schools ten different
groupings that they actually just
figured out through some spreadsheet
manipulation type of thing and the the
state and the federal government was
like no that's too many so we're like
okay we'll just limit it to ten which
was fine because this problem is so
unconstrained that it's extremely hard
so even limiting it to ten was like not
a bad thing for us anyway and you do end
up with effectively three groups at the
end you know even though you start with
ten
structured clustering um especially when
you need to like just drops especially
you know in the data science set and to
use some unstructured methods would be
like oh yeah this is great
you know I mean I think there could be a
lot of different approaches to this
I think I'm not quite sure what you mean
by unstructured clustering but right
well I mean just keeping in mind that
we're trying to get at the maximum
reimbursement was always our goal so you
know I think different clustering
methods would have different types of
purposes so we were trying to always
kind of get to that goal and like I said
I think sure there are a lot of
different I mean we'd love to hear if
anyone has some more ideas of what to do
I think I think that it's it's
definitely I think another thing we
considered was genetic algorithms which
you can kind of see this as almost a
part of it like a genetic algorithm
holding mutations but I mean you can
imagine there are there are other ways
of getting at in the end this is like
you're just trying to get the maximum so
yeah the real quick thing that I would
add to that too is that I I do see
underneath this there is some clustering
going on based on you know like the the
rate that kids eat lunch at schools and
the the rate at which they are
identified to get a free lunch is not
random there's demographic factors
underlying that we just didn't use here
at all and I think another approach
would have been to you know cluster
based on those and you would see
different groups with different
characteristics and then you could maybe
try to mash them too
right but just to Dina's point again I I
think given that we had you know the
exact math in front of us this was the
quickest way to it yeah I think we can
do that yeah so the 65% means that in
those schools that were in that 65
percent threshold 65% of the lunches
were being reimbursed at the full rate
and the rest were being reimbursed at a
lower rate whereas the cluster that was
near a hundred percent it means every
single one of those lunches where it was
reimbursed at the full well I mean we
work for city government there's tons of
projects there's like tons of projects I
think our main focus is always trying to
get the projects that have long-term
impact within city government and those
that actually provide services to New
Yorkers so this was an example of you
know this is providing lunches to school
kids and wanting that to be you know
universal across everyone so these are
the kinds of things that we really kind
of look for but I don't know I don't
know if I have any like off the top of
my head
like sanitation and rats and stuff I'm
not quite sure what it would be okay
thanks thank you